[Music]
on the sandy shores of the Florida Keys
sea turtles are laying their eggs but a
threat is looming for these gentle
creatures the Caribbean climate has
become increasingly unpredictable as
rising sea levels [ __ ] the beaches
where these Turtles handling tasks they
come back to their natal pieces so
animals that were born here are coming
back to this very little spit of land in
order to lay their own eggs
if the beach goes away they may not be
as flexible to use another beach dr.
Kristen Hart and her team of researchers
are working around the clock tagging and
tracking these Turtles in an effort to
protect their future their imperiled
they do need help and we're trying to
figure out you know where the problems
are
we are here on HP in Dry Tortugas
National Park we are about 70 miles west
of Key West and we're in the Gulf of
Mexico there are seven islands we are on
one of the smallest but one of the
densest turtle nesting beaches some of
them are right on top of each other a
foot away from each other this is a
almost completely Marine Park and the
turtles come up and grace us with their
presence it's been amazing to see these
animals up close and personal with them
and we get you know right in there and
generally sea turtles date back to the
time of the dinosaurs so it's 200
million years of evolution our study was
the first to really concentrate on the
Dry Tortugas turtles our goals are to
try to determine patterns of movement
and habitat use to figure out where they
might go
[Music]
all these points are either sightings or
capture points when we first started
working here we realized that we could
dipnet juvenile green turtles I had done
this in the Everglades and out here the
water is much more clear we can pursue
them in the flats and shallower areas
the bigger turtles out here we do what's
called rodeo capture or also turtle
jumping they're usually 10 or 15 feet
down but when they need to come get a
breath they're coming up to the surface
so that's when the diver meets them down
there you basically get your hands sort
of on the rear and right behind the head
and you get the animal pointed up at the
team effort once we get them on board
the boat will do a standard workup which
includes measuring them weighing them
taking blood samples tissue samples
there's a lot of questions that we can
ask even just about how healthy they are
and how healthy then are the resources
that they're using
we also fix devices on them to track
their movements so we've used acoustic
telemetry radio telemetry and the
satellite tracking so we're learning a
lot about the movement paths and their
their areas of residence they've been
around the globe but they're hard wired
to come back to the very place where
they were born to lay their own eggs if
an animal was born on a ski she'll come
back to you see she's not going to go
use loggerhead key or one of the other
keys here
we all take turns every 30 minutes
walking around this beach in particular
it takes about ten minutes to walk
around if they mess we let them nest and
mark off where the nest is and then we
work her up just like the same work up
we would do with a little fertile
she's corralled in a box because they
can be 400 pounds and they're very
powerful they'll do that about every two
weeks during a season and when you I get
recaptures that's really exciting
because you know the animal still
survived wherever she went
in order for turtles to lay their eggs
the conditions have to be just right
ideally they'll encounter high tides
dark beaches and warm sea surface
temperatures otherwise they'll do
something called a fall scroll in which
a turtle will make their way onto the
beach only to turn back around we don't
know really why they fall scar but
something isn't right maybe they're not
feeling contractions
maybe the conditions are certain right
at that spot maybe they dig and they hit
a piece of coral or a roof or something
like that and fall scroll could become
more frequent rising sea levels reduce
the amount of available beach space and
rising temperatures can tragically
effects that temperature studies show
that cooler nest temperatures produce
more males while warmer nest generally
produce females with sea level rise and
climate change they're threatened I
think we're a little more concerned
about their trajectory of their
populations because it's generally not
good for the turtle
[Music]
we've learned a lot about these dry
tortugas turtles and it really is
valuable to me to know that they value
the research that we're contributing
we're answering questions that are
important that haven't been asked before
it's definitely demanding but at the
same time I think it's one of the most
rewarding things we could ever do there
aren't many people allowed on this
little patch of land so I feel very
privileged to be able to play a role in
you know figuring these Turtles out and
being in this very special place
[Music]